okay hello today so i'm gonna talk about
the reason that i left islam so i was
really confused really shocked
so i was trying to say the right thing
but i became like a criminal so i
decided
to leave islam that's the reason why see
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
how are you it's a pleasure to have you
now the lockdown is over 100 we can hug
each other yes
nice yes no can get off me now please
okay
so i watched the video somebody sent it
to me and he's given his reasons why he
left islam
and i realized that when i watched it
that it is pertaining to what happened
with brother dawud kim and the whole
controversy and the
you know the mistake that he did may
allah forgive him inshallah and
this actually connects well me saying
may allah forgive him actually connects
to why he left islam
whoa so let's actually watch it for
ourselves and understand where
this prophet is coming from inshallah
yeah and maybe answer those doubts if
he's watching this i'm sure he's going
to be watching this inshallah
and let's come to a common understanding
because sometimes shaytan comes and
deceives us in certain ways especially
i'm reading a book called the deception
of shaytan it's quite interesting you
need to read it yeah yeah
yes so let's watch it and let's see what
was the reason why he left
okay hello today so i'm gonna talk about
the reason
that i left islam this is just my
personal
opinion and this is my
experiences so i hope you can understand
so he does mention that it is his
experiences
yes so he's talking about personal
experience after a youtuber
incident happened i just
really shocked because i didn't know
that every crime every commitment
can be justified after became muslim
okay so he mentioned something very um i
think when this whole issue
happened with the double kim et cetera
when you saw that wasn't you disturbed
yeah yeah of course yeah okay people
were talking yes so when i saw it
obviously i was disturbed in the context
of okay it was wrong
yeah what was done and when he came in
admittedly because it's time for you
that's when it it started hitting the
fans and then people said so now what
he's saying is that he's saying he
he had a problem within his inner self
that how is it that in islam something
like this
can just be forgiven yeah now is that
the case in islam that for example when
you come to islam we know we tell a lot
of rivers
all your sins are white but we do say
that for example that
there's three conditions for someone
repenting so there's uh three conditions
if you commit a sin
but there's four conditions if you wrong
someone so if you make a sin against
yourself you have to repent hate it and
don't go back to it try
you vow to not go back to it the fourth
conditions what we are told is what
that if you have wronged someone else
you have to ask for their forgiveness
so what he's saying that do you think
maybe the brother himself
misunderstood that when we come and say
to reverse okay all your sins are
forgiven
that if i stole from someone i'm not
going to be cold i'll just become a
muslim brother i don't know
anything or you know what i punch you in
the face i'm a muslim now
it doesn't work like that is that right
or wrong
well to be honest i mean islam is a
practical religion yes whether whether
people agree with it or not whether
people
like it or not and practically speaking
people are sinners they do stuff
especially outside of islam i mean even
companions they used to do
um drinking alcohol also burying their
daughters alive
but if you have this concept that you
know sins aren't going to be forgiven
then there's no hope
you you're left in a pit of hopelessness
very valid
so yes you do need to be there needs to
be some sort of consequence and we're
obviously living in non-muslim land so
if you have raped somebody or
something's happened then
naturally the police will get involved
and that's that's the law that we're
governed for if
it was yeah okay let's watch i'm gonna i
don't know yeah and i didn't know that
it was wrong thing which is
uh i revealed the truth about my brother
so in islam revealing bad truth
about brother is very big sin i sense
from the brother is the follower i might
be wrong i feel like this and
it's a bit emotional in the context i'm
not disregarding but i feel like he's
hurt
he's like hold on a second i found this
out
or i don't know who brought it out to
the public but i don't know if he was
involved i don't know the situation
but he's saying oh okay oh i was a very
bad person then i guess i'm so sorry for
doing that
what we're saying is when we submit
submit all to allah we have to abide by
the laws allah's legislative
yeah we might logically think no that's
the right thing to do
but when it comes to islam pertaining to
islam like like
said yeah if it was logic we would wipe
underneath our socks not on top of it
so the thing is there's some things we
have to put trust in allah and his
messenger so what he's saying is he's
saying that okay i got like it seems
like he got attacked
because he came out with this and he was
condemning um
what the world did so he's thinking okay
so i'm now to blame
because i think it's confusing two
things bro we're saying look
what you have done now islamically
should have you come up with it
i don't know about that but you not
liking what he did
and you wanting him to maybe get
punished for what he did
that's not wrong per se that's not wrong
islam doesn't say you're not allowed to
believe what he did is wrong you're not
allowed to no no nobody's saying that
what we're saying is don't confuse two
things islam has a religion if that
happened in an
islamic country run by the sharia that
would came because he
attempted something he didn't do i'm
trying to understand where he's coming
from because
islamically you've misinterpreted
something and you've made it seem as if
he's totally forgiven which is not the
case in the context of
yes if he repented but if he lived in
the and
the land uh the islamic land there would
have been a prescribed punishment or
whatever it may be
so i'm just sensing that there's some
kind of a
he's hurt like the people that have
commented and i think he got a lot of
hate in the comments
i think that's interesting because uh
your videos are rubbish
thank you and uh you shut down your
channel okay
nice you get comments like that isn't it
oh yes i always actually say that
have you shut down your channel no do
you stop doing your videos no
uh some people they can handle hate some
people they can't handle hate and the
muslim community because we're in the
muslim community we know
especially amongst the orthodox crowd
they can be a bit
rough around the edges and it's just
something that you know it's it's
unfortunate but you just get used to it
you can't blame islam because of the
people exactly there's all kinds of
people and some of them yeah like you
know and dawood has
always he had like a million subscribers
he had a big
regular following and for you to
naturally speak against somebody like
that
we've seen it with other youtubers that
we're not mentioning names but when you
speak against them or when somebody else
speaks against them their crowd comes
whether they're
right or wrong yes because they can't
handle those two conflicting thoughts
exactly
cognitive dissonance exactly and some
it's a big word that is martial i feel
like i'm same with hijab
the point is this yeah sometimes
sometimes you have to i've noticed in my
life here as a muslim book
if it was for muslims i would have left
islam a long time ago
what certain muslims have done to me
yeah and from all angles yeah okay
okay what they've done to me i could
have left islam yeah but the point is i
have to sometimes say you know what
i think it's time for me to turn to the
kitab of allah because i need to divorce
the muslims from islam sometimes
and i had to do that for my own sanity
because i'm looking i know where he's
coming from i understand but does it
justify for you
to um leave islam yeah and there's a
very specific verse in surah
yeah uh which inshallah we're going to
read in a minute because it's so
profound and
if the brother is watching this please
we're coming from a place of love we're
not here look you want to leave islam
you want that's up to you at the moment
it doesn't seem
like the reasons are big misconceptions
they can hold to academic rigor
exactly yeah they they're a bit you know
i think you can
speak to somebody of knowledge or you
can retrace your steps leaving
an entire way of life i think it's a bit
of a it's
a rash decision yeah take your time
analyze the things again
it seems like it could be because you
try to genuinely
thanks for that it could be uh genuinely
because you thought
somebody was doing something wrong and
then so many people came out but there's
many reasons for that it could be
because of his fan following
it could be because people didn't you
know know you maybe you mis
articulated your your argument or maybe
people only watch the start of the video
there's so many reasons my bro
it doesn't mean that because of that
allah now stops existing
or the prophet's message evaporated into
thin air that allah is still there
the message is still there yes the way
people have interpreted that message or
the way that message has permeated their
souls
is is different it varies from person to
person
so i was really confused
really short so i was trying to say the
right thing
but i became like a criminal and every
youtuber
defend him and even though he admitted
he did bad things which is not a small
thing
it's a big thing actually and no one
is thinking about the victim i think
look i'm one of the youtubers that done
a video and i addressed the issue
um because there was it was doubly sword
and if someone can repent
imagine you turning away someone and
this is why it's very fundamental
because if it was up to mankind like me
and you
actually we would finish people off well
i know some people
s pubs well like they would one mistake
they think i don't finish
i i sometimes thank allah that these
certain muslims were life they were my
judge i'm finished
i thank allah that allah is going to
judge me because i'm like if you judge
me you would
cut me into pieces slice by slice
so the question is that alhamdulillah it
shows
that with the brother he has a concern
but it's as if he
he's seeing like you know someone
shouldn't be forgiven that's not fair
and the thing is you know when you've
done something wrong
yeah you get forgiven yes there's a
victim and yes there's a due process
but the thing is think about it islam is
so amazing
that it's protecting more victims from
emerging
because a person having hope and a
person being forgiven they're more
likely to
rectify themselves if the past is not
forgiven they're going to continue
there's going to be more victims because
there's a sense of hopelessness
oh i've done it now i'm not going to get
forgiven i might as well carry on well
there's a story of the prophet
sorrow about from about the man who
killed 99 people and he wanted
forgiveness and they went to the monk
and the monk said you're not going to be
forgiven he said well i might as well
kill you
yeah exactly so how when people lose
hope so what we're just trying to say
here
is that people should be forgiven and
like allah says in the quran
for example you kill somebody either an
eiffel knight
either blood money anyone says it's best
for you to forgive
and the thing is here i want to say one
other thing which is don't
learn your islam from comments on
youtube
on on a drama i mean the dean you can't
reduce the deen to such a a kind of
cheap
charade yeah there's this entire
academic rigor
background spirituality 1400 years worth
of
tradition
they have issues they message us threats
me he drives
up i'm gonna come and do i need a muslim
i think you deserve it
so i was considering is this really
right path for me and
people always give me advices
and then i gave them advices
oppositely then i became [ __ ]
i just couldn't understand all of this i
i
rather want to become an honest person
rather than lying liar
see this is where he's trying to say i
rather become honest than lying so what
he's trying to say i think he's coming
from a good place he's saying look
i was just being honest i was being
sincere to myself i was trying to stick
up for someone that's been wrong
and if i'm going to be attacked i don't
want to be a part of it we're saying
look
that's all well and good i don't doubt
you was honest i don't doubt you were
sincere i don't doubt that you genuinely
cared about the victim
but what we're saying is that do not
conflate that because when you say that
that's islam to me honesty sincerity
caring about others okay that's islam
islam islam all over
the prophet peace be upon him said
moving that harmful object from the
world is the lowest part of iman
yeah um for subhanallah being sincere
honest the prophet
said the believer is anything but a liar
the person said a believer is anything
but a lie you're not allowed to lie
so i don't want this brother to feel
like these are two opposites like okay i
had to leave islam to become
sincere and honest and truthful no this
is islam but please don't judge it by
people
yeah so i decided to leave
islam that's the reason why see yeah but
genuinely brother if you're watching
this or
you look as if it's your life brother
you can whatever you want to do you want
to leave go
whatever you want to do but the question
that i want to ask and i want to finish
with this
verse in the quran because it's very
very powerful yeah
and we want that inshallah let's let's
let's listen to that recitation from
muhammad and come back in sha allah
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
[Music]
beautiful recitation let's read it in
english so we can understand inshallah
so allah says in the quran and i think
this is a beautiful way to finish this
video like this amazing what allah
says in the quran do people think that
they will be left at ease only if
they're saying we believe and will not
be put to test
look allah is talking yeah do you think
you're going to say allah not be tested
third verse indeed we have tested those
who were before them
so allah will surely know the ones who
are truthful and he will surely know the
ones who are liars and you are going to
be tested and i would say to myself ali
deep down i know i might exist i can't
deny that he's lying to my face looking
in the mirror and saying
you're lying to yourself i know allah
exists i know islam is the truth
i know the process is the prophet
salallahu
i cannot live in a lie yeah so what i
said is i said look
it's time to divorce that muslim from
islam and what i would do is go back to
the quran let's go back to the book of
allah
because these people are letting me down
and you should never tie your happiness
to individuals
among men there are those who say we
believe in allah but when they are
persecuted in the way of allah
they take the persecution of men as
equal to the punishment of allah and
should any
should any help come from your lord they
will certainly say
we were with you it is not that allah
knows well what lies in the hearts of
the people of the world
subhanallah this is so powerful because
they saying you're taking the
persecution
and the wrongdoings of man mankind like
the same of
same allah allah would um
sorry among the men with the lord
exactly
so what we're just seeing is brothers
and sisters in a nutshell all i can say
is
we're going to be tested and brother if
you're watching this maybe just
reevaluate take it take your time out
and like i said the choice is yours
nobody can stop you
but that's what i have to say often is
there anything you'd like to enter yeah
i mean uh to to be honest it sounds
like we we have all the time in the
world and
you know we can afford to play around
with these decisions but when
these eyes close and these eyes open
that's when we'll see the actual reality
and then you don't be in a position
where you start saying what if and i
wish i could go back and
regret is one of the one of the
strongest
and most difficult emotions to overcome
and we're actually saying look there's
no there's no
there's no benefit to me if you stay or
you go or to ali
we're just saying look please for the
sake of your akhirah
do what you what is in your hands i'll
just end with this here
my like sometimes people in my family
members say oh you see that muslim ruler
this muslim
etc um he's like this is like he's a
muslim i'm like look
i say like to my family members when i
stand in front of allah that's not going
to ask me about him
yeah i'm going to ask answered about
myself
it was a pleasure may allah bless you
inshallah i know how hard it is to have
a straight face with you
but you really did we have to admire
that yeah yeah i worked very hard
he was very difficult he did and we want
to thank mahdi job for his brutal
recitation
till next time brother sisters goodbye